all right next up to talk about we've
got a bunch of games to get through here
folks and I want to talk about the
division next we've seen the division at
ubisoft conference a couple years in a
row here this is the third year they've
had a big fanfare aranda is it just me
or does this game look not really as
pretty as it did a couple of years are
you going down the watchdog's room I
don't say like this downgrade nonsense
but like man like the dip Ghost Recon
trailer looked better than what I saw
from the division well we'll come back
to that in two years time I see yeah I
don't know it's i'm happy about today's
game play because it finally showed off
the sort of online connectability what
it means to be playing this game with a
bunch of people and running into other
people now also that ryan guy god what
the end of the demo something the other
thing is i mean we've seen a lot of
these multiplayer playthroughs on the
press conferences but no one's really
acting like they would in a real
multi-play situation apart from that guy
griefs everyone at the end so what we
saw in the demo was that the the sort of
the main human team here we're following
three characters going around basically
doing a mission in the in the world of
the division get accosted by this other
group of bad online players and then he
sort of band together and then at the
end they decide to turn on them and then
on the end it turns out the one of their
friends decided to turn on them as well
so this thing really lose interesting to
me I mean other games of a kane and
lynch is the first game that comes to
mind it's done this before but what's
interesting about that is in kane and
lynch had always just devolved into
everybody's just going to betray
everybody else in whatever and so my mic
my first question would be what's to
keep that from being a thing that you do
what is the key that you know it sounds
like a good idea but in practice is it
really going to be meaningful or is it
always just going to end up being the
same anyway yeah i'm really curious
about that yeah it's good to see them
show off a little bit more of the
connectability stuff but still it's it's
almost that thing we're so intrigued by
that there are as many questions that
get answered we get our loads more
questions like for instance why do you
leave at Christmas tree lit up when
electricity it seems to have gone out
and most of the city okay
you know the spirit of Christmas lives
on daddy because sometimes you need a
good shot and sometimes the shot
overrides logic in film and in-game
joint I see this is the crow essential
moment where I he's like now I'm not
gonna help you uh pro- you off because
this is internet video games God look at
the numbers guns him down yeah is there
stuff kind of just looks at them stairs
him in the ILO but we also got a date
for the division at March 8 2016 you
look forward to not slipping probably
one more time before cynics all of us
cynics I I'm really excited for the
division I like it on paper I like the
idea of the interconnected multiplayer
the idea of being in groups I'm a little
bit down on the graphic stuff final
thoughts on the division Alexa what do
you think I don't know I'm sort of i
feel like there are so many military
shooters or military s cuter yeah newbie
stop speaking all of them yeah I don't
know I some still I still don't think
I've seen anything different other than
I guess the ability to turn on your team
yeah and take their stuff so how do you
think was you know I could've like I
like the idea um it kinda reminded me a
little bit of I'm alive yuba social yeah
fabled another post apocalyptic game boy
I just had that kind of feeling you know
when the two groups kind of came up
against each other and you're like to I
trust him door not mailed it in man I
mean that game could have been so much
so much more but maybe some of the ideas
went into a Division I don't know might
look sad I'm still cautious than too
excited yeah Kevin final thoughts yeah
it's still same pretty much cautiously
optimistic about it perhaps because i
want the destiny asked to be a
burgeoning genre of its own that's
worthy of getting attention and this is
the one game right now that seems to be
really following in those footsteps and
i really want a better type of Destiny
game so maybe this will be it maybe not
maybe 2016 is the year of that sort of
maybe there's more and more of these
games at coming after ya yeah destiny to
coming at e3 2016 what we were playing
at the division by the time that comes
out march 8 2016 is when hopefully as
long as doesn't slip will all be playing
the division and if you want any updates
on that game of course stay tuned right
here to gamespot com
you